Lánh tụi tôi Kau Iran most acabar khai mình này được ra thông việp trên chuyên thêm trong đó cảnh báo Mỹ
Vậy Serial về thức bại kai đăng mới, nếu tí tục cạnh đập của sửa nhằm bởi
Iran. Ông khai mình này khẳng định lực lượng 2 Kun Iran con gần vị bú Changh Phát,
đang trong trẳng khai sánh dành cao, thông dẹp đưa ra đúng sịp kỳ nhận ngày thành lập
hôm đầu Iran. Lánh tụi Iran cho rằng các lực lượng đúng tránh hôm này đã bảo vệ hiệu quả
chùa của Lánh Hồ. Châu Âb lực tụi Mỹ Vậy Serial, đồng thời mong tả để là mình chứng
sự thích bại của đối phương trên đủ liệu. Châu Âb lực tụi Mỹ Vậy Serial,
cho bố cảnh khẳng bắn chưa hành nhận. Lánh hùng bắn thậm tự giới văn là Mỹ
dự kiến dễ thạm và ngày hành hai thứng tư. Các bòng làm phản cần đầy giữa
hại bên tại Pakistan chưa đặt tiếp qua bị nhìn một đề của lỗi. Báo gồm chuy trình
hạp nhân của Iran và kìm sát yếu biển thông ốc. Châu Âb Mỹ để xuất định chỉ giải hạ.
Êván chỉ xem sách khắp phần ảm ngắm hơn. Tìm chứ của thơ điểm cuộc thề cho phòng làm phản tiếp theo.
Trong khi các nỗ lực trung ra em tiếp tục đủ đủ đầy em chẳng liệu thân căng thần.